Oh Jafar you did an amazing job at
raising J sure you turned him into a
master thief but unlike the rest of the
B case you and J had a pretty strong
relationship
he stole things to help you run your
shop and he rubbed every lamp you came
across just in case it was the one you
were searching for J is always there for
his friends and he's got family values
in the bag so we guess what we're trying
to say is thank you for giving us Jay
Jay has changed a lot throughout the
descendants franchise but we didn't
realize just how much he had evolved
until we watched descendents three here
are 10 things nobody realizes about Jay
when we first meet Jay it didn't take a
song to find out that he had sticky
fingers Jay could shake your hand and
swipe your wallet and you'd be none the
wiser Jay continued to steal stuff when
he first came over to our Adan but it
didn't take long for his fingers to lose
their grip we couldn't believe our eyes
when Jay stopped Harry from stealing in
a case wallet in his tendons 3 wow he
sure has come a long way Jay loves his
freedom and everything that comes with
it
he plans to travel and embark on more
adventures than he can count although
it's hard to believe Jay is the only
single VK out of the original core for
Evie has dug mal has been and Carlos has
Jane and when it comes today he's got
adventure on the brain Jay doesn't seem
to mind the single life he looks happy
to be on his own in descendants 3 but
Jay is never alone because his fellow
BK's have quickly become his family and
Jay values family above all else when
the V case were given the task of
choosing a recruit Jay chose to pair up
with Carlos and pick the Smee twins Jay
wanted to keep the twins together no
matter what he knows how important it is
to be surrounded by family which is why
he would never separate squeaky and
squirmy floating up the twins so get
over here squirmy come on the wild Jay
may be content with hanging out with the
fam there is one person he didn't bother
mentioning throughout the film and
that's Lonnie most of us thought that
Jay and Lonnie would be an item by
descendants 3 because well they totally
hit it off in D 2 but for some strange
reason Jay remains single throughout the
three call and never once mentions his
could've
girlfriend we wonder what happened
between these two although we don't get
the full story we do know that Lonnie is
spending most of her time with her
swords and shields team and since Jay
loves sports he would never stop her
from following her passions Jays real
passion on the other hand is playing
horny
he's the tourney team's star player and
he proudly wears number eight on his
back did you guys notice how Jay usually
sports an embroidered Cobra on his fact
he loves to represent too far and he
does this on the tour knee field to his
number eight it's easily switch top for
a Cobra mimicking the infinity sign
where as Carlos wants to become a
veterinarian Jay wants to become a
professional Tour knee player Jay's
dream is to go pro and become a torna
coach once he's done playing the field
so while mal and Ben will be busy
brewing over our Don and the aisle Jay
will be touring the world and playing
his favorite sports it takes a lot of
guts to go after our dreams but Jay
knows what he wants and he's not afraid
to go after it
and luckily for our Don Jace one of the
bravest few caves of all time this was
proven in d3 when Hades managed to sneak
his head and arm out of the barrier Jay
was the first one to charge Hades his
bravery is undeniable but unfortunately
it resulted in him being the first one
to get blasted by Hades
luckily mouths dad didn't actually hurt
anyone
J has always been brave which makes us
wonder if this is something his father
taught him he might have noticed how J
is the only VK out of the core four to
have a single father instead of a single
mother but the scale tipped in D Simmons
3 when Hades was revealed as Mal's dad
now both mal and J have father figures
in their lives but who could Jay's
mother be if you have any theories
comment them down below some people
believe that Jays mom was a pirate and
the reason behind this assumption makes
sense in return to the Isle of the Lost
Jay gets approached to join Captain
Hook's pirate crew however Jay refuses
and continues to help his father run his
shop it would make sense for Jays mom to
be a pirate since he was approached by
Captain Hook
but in the end Jay ended up being close
friends with uma Harry and Gil so he
might very well have the C coursing
through his veins I want to get a kick
out of a Barry bish we were happy to see
Jay hit it off with Gil because well Jay
seemed to be a little lonely in
descendents 3 while Jay had plenty of
friends they were all in relationships
and making future plans without him so
finding a friend like Gil was super
important Jay looks so excited when he
started bonding with Gil and now the
boys have plans to travel the world for
the entire year you know it will be fun
to go rafting in a jungle River find a
lot of civilization or maybe a penguin
we wish we could watch their adventures
on the small screen what do you say you
me go exploring I'll do a gap year
jungles or icebergs both so did you guys
notice anything else about Jay and
descendants 3 sound off in the comments
section descendants 3 the truth about
Jay and thanks for watching hit that
subscribe button and don't forget to
give this video a big thumbs up we'll
catch you next time on two things
[Music]